Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Link.
And I am Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're gonna do the Q&A that
we said that we didn't know
if we wanted to do.
That's right.
The "Lost Years" series,
all along the way,
we prompted you guys to use #EarBiscuits
and let us know how you were processing
and if particular questions
arose, let us know.
And I don't think we
said if concerns arose,
let us know, but I
guess that happened too.
Yeah.
Well, what we talked about last week
was how we're processing this whole thing
and how we have a tendency, I think,
maybe me more than Link,
I have a tendency to,
once I start looking at questions
and thinking about what
people are saying and asking,
I start wanting to defend
myself and to justify myself
especially if I see that I'm kind
of being misunderstood or misrepresented.
But I am becoming a healthier
person as I get older
and I am learning more
ways, just me and my ego
and so we decided to instead
of getting into answering
questions last week,
to kind of just get into our process,
but also what we talked about was
we don't want this
podcast to become a place
where we're just gonna
spout off our opinions
when it comes to things
that we're ultimately
not qualified to talk about.
And so, because you can very
quickly get into this place
where two guys who basically
have been making a living on YouTube
for over a decade, are sitting
around and trying to tell you
their particular apologetic, prospective--
Giving persuasive arguments
for what beliefs you should adopt
is not something that we're gonna do.
Because there's a lot of people out there
who have dedicated their lives
to studying some of the
things that we talked about
and they're experts in their field
and there are so many books
that have been written,
articles that have been written
about all the things that we talked about.
So it is up to you to go
and do your own research,
come to your own conclusions.
But I do think that there
were a lot of questions
that were asked just
from a very curious place
like we told long
stories about our stories
and our faith journeys
and we condensed them down
into less than two hours.
We left a lot of details out,
we left a lot of people wondering
about different parts of the process,
wondering about how we think
about particular things now
and I've seen a lot of questions
kind of grouped together.
So, I thought and also
I think these questions
have also been coming from the Christians
that we stay in contact
with in our own lives,
which is one question that we got.
You guys, are you guys
still friends with Christ?
Yes, we're still friends
with lots of Christians
and we've got really
close lifelong friends
who are still presidents of seminaries
and Old Testament professors and pastors.
And so, we've got a lot of people who
can challenge a lot of
the things that we said
and we're in conversation.
But I think a lot of those questions
come from a curious place
and so we want to honor your questions,
honor your curiosity
and just kind of give
our personal perspective.
This isn't designed to be like
this is what you should think.
This isn't prescriptive.
This is just to kind of fill
in the gap of your curiosity
if you have it.
Yeah, so you've grouped
together some questions
which you're gonna tee up.
I know some of these but not all of them
but yeah, for me, our
stories are so different
that they engendered a
different flavor of response
and when your story talks
so much about the issues
that it did, it invites people to engage
on this apologetics level,
on this reasons for believing
certain things level,
whereas I'm not getting as much as that.
So, I think I'm grateful
because I didn't want that,
well I decidedly--
You shouldn't feel bad.
You seem like you almost felt bad
about not getting
I told my story in the way that I told it,
piggybacking off of your story
because it would drive me
nuts to have the responses
that are directly addressed to your story.
Well,
It would just it would
that was not a healthy environment
and so I'm glad that the
way that I told my story
even though a lot of what you experienced,
again I was there for
it and we discussed it
and I was the sounding board
and I didn't shut any of that down.
Yeah, well I stand by what I
said when you told your story
which is I think that your story
is ultimately more relatable
to more people than mine is
but people who think--
Maybe we'll come back to
what the difference is
in response and the
magnitude of responses,
what that means.
All right.
All I'll say right now is
that people who think like me
also behave like me which is,
they talk more about this
particular type thing.
They make YouTube channels
about it.
They make make podcasts
and YouTube channels about it.
They set up events where
they debate about it.
Right, and so--
That ain't me.
Yeah.
And that's how I am
If I was still in the faith,
I would be right there alongside them.
If I was like that, we'd have
a totally different podcast
and a totally different online persona,
I guess at this point.
But so I will say before
you get into those questions
that the main thing that
people responded to my story
was like the stories that I told,
and particularly the story about
you leaving me on the side of the road.
So, if you're more interested
in the story aspect of things,
once we get through some
of these other questions,
we'll come back to that
because people are interested
in your point of view--
Because I didn't say anything
On that particular day, right.
And I will say, I mean now
we're six and a half minutes in
but if you happen to be someone
who's just checking out Ear
Biscuits for the first time
and you got to this point,
and you're not overly confused
I think they've gathered
that they missed something.
Yeah, we did a whole series.
First of all, this podcast
is just two buddies
who've known each other forever
just trying to figure out life together,
being friends and
talking about the process
and things that we're interested in.
And one of the things that we
decided to do over a month ago
is to kind of tell our full stories
of our evangelical Christian backgrounds,
how that got us to where
we're at in our careers.
It played an integral role
and what we call "The Lost Years"
We call them "The Lost Years"
because they were literally
never talked about
until we talked about them on the podcast.
I find it hard to believe
this is the first episode
anyone's listened to.
But somebody might be.
And you know what?
Those were long episodes, just skip them.
No, I would love you to listen to them.
So we told our individual
deconstruction stories
and we asked you to participate
in asking some questions
and now we're gonna finally.
Well, we did another podcast
where we talked about how we didn't feel,
how we didn't know what we were gonna do
by answering questions.
But now we're gonna answer some questions.
Okay.
One of the things, again I'm
not gonna credit anybody.
Maybe it will come at some
of these later questions,
but again, this is me this was a group.
So these are all from Link
Okay, yeah.
These are from multiple people
so you asked yourself "What if I'm wrong?"
I said that during my story.
There was a point in which
when I was a Christian
and I had experienced a bunch of doubts,
I said "What if I'm wrong?"
Do you ask yourself that question now?
What if you're wrong now?
That's that question.
Yeah, because it seems like
our belief on the inside,
it was like a hedging your bets
Occam's razor kind of
what if you're wrong.
It's like worst case you know,
worst case on the outside,
you're risking eternal punishment,
separation from God, right?
I think you're talking
about Pascal's Wager.
Pascal's Wager.
Occam's razor.
Occam razor.
I can't even say it now,
it's the simplest solution solution.
The simple solution.
The Pascal's Wager is essentially
right, we're gonna place Pascal,
famous mathematician and thinker
from a long time ago who was a Christian
basically said what do I have to lose
by living a Christian life you know
because I get to.
You have a lot to gain.
You have a lot to lose by
going to the dark side.
Which I wanna talk a little bit
about Hell in a second
related to Pascal's Wager
and why I don't find it compelling.
But yeah, but the question,
what if you're wrong?
What about Occam's razor, though, are
you gonna talk about that?
Occam's razor,
I shave with it every day.
I shave underneath my
beard with Occam's razor.
Well, what's your response?
Yes, I asked myself if I'm wrong.
I hope I never stop doing it.
Like I said at the end of the podcast,
the moment I told my story it's like,
if anything, I have
demonstrated a willingness
to change my mind right,
to sort of extricate myself from something
that is still very much
a part of the way I think
and the way that I behave
was my entire worldview
in my entire orienting principle in life
and I moved away from it
in spite of wanting to not want to...
I didn't want to stop believing it.
And so yeah, I continue to
ask myself that question.
I hope I hope I never stop
asking myself the question,
"What if I'm wrong?"
I will say that though,
the flavor of the question
has changed a little bit
because I no longer have
real definitive ideas
about things that I find
hard to be definitive about.
Like I don't know what I
think about the afterlife.
I have some guesses
but I don't have any
convictions about the afterlife.
I don't have any convictions
about the supernatural
reality of the world
and so therefore, when I had certainty
about those things, and I knew
that I was gonna go to heaven
and that people who
ultimately disagreed with me
were gonna go to hell, "What
if I'm wrong?" felt different.
Absolutely.
I feel now like I don't have to be right.
I felt like I had to be right before
and you know, if I didn't feel confident
about a certain aspect of my rightness,
I had to bolster that.
I had to reload a little
something about it.
You know I think that if you had a doubt
about the resurrection of Jesus,
then you would google
evidence for the resurrection.
And it will come in droves.
And it took a long time for me to get
to a point where I'm like,
I'm actually gonna Google evidence
against the resurrection,
just to check it out.
But I guess, since the
shoe's on the other foot,
I should ask us, well now
are we Googling things like
evidence for the resurrection?
And I think that's a
later question you have
so we can go back to it.
Yeah, yeah.
We'll come back to it, keep
going, this is almost fun.
A related question that
kind of comes on the heels
of what if you're wrong
is what about Hell?
Do you not live in fear that what like
if you if you were right,
in the first you know three
quarters of your life,
you were right, then this
version of you who is wrong
is going to hell.
And not only are you going to hell
but you're leading your
family, your best friend
and anyone who's
listening to your podcast,
potentially you're leading--
Your fans.
You're leading them to hell.
What about the impressionable fans?
Okay, so the first part of the question--
The personal, are you scared of Hell?
Okay, okay.
Are you're scared of Hell?
My answer to this is that
when I was a Christian,
I was not scared of all the
other potential outcomes
as presented by all the other religions.
Right?
So according to some
conservative flavors of Islam,
I would have been considered an infidel
and probably would have
gotten into paradise.
The Muslim concept of hell's
a little bit different
in how you qualify for it.
But whatever, there are some people
who believe a certain thing in that faith
who would have said that
I was going to hell.
There are some people who
believe in reincarnation
and might believe that,
based on my actions
I was gonna come back a grasshopper,
whatever the particular
and now I'm not trying
to make light of that,
I'm just saying that that
could be somebody's idea.
I didn't lose any sleep about
those potential outcomes
when I was a Christian
because as a Christian
I had a very long list of people's beliefs
about the afterlife that I
was that I didn't believe.
I wasn't scared of their hell
because I didn't believe in it.
There's a very long list if
you really tried to make it.
Right.
So the only thing I've done
is I've added the Christian
hell to that list of things
that I don't believe in
and so it becomes you know,
it's not as easy as a mental
exercise as I just made it seem
because when you believe in it for so long
and that's what you thought
when you were in your formative years,
your adolescent years,
it's a little bit more
difficult to disregard.
But I would say that sort
of the short answer is
I don't lose any sleep about it
for the same reason
that you as a Christian
don't lose sleep about going
to someone else's hell.
And I didn't lose sleep about Hell
when I believed I had escaped it.
And I think it was just something
that I did not like to think about,
like I mean you might think that with all
the experience that I described
and like the guilt and the pressure
that I placed on myself
within that belief system,
you might think that there was
a direct connection to Hell
like there's a lot of people
who with a similar makeup as me
would then take the next step to like
well God, am I really saved?
I gotta make sure I'm saved every day.
I gotta pray that sinner's prayer.
Well, Jesse was told,
my wife Jesse who went
to a very conservative
Christian private school,
was told when she was a kid
and of course she struggles
with scrupulosity,
the scrupulous a version of OCD.
So this is especially
troublesome for her they say.
Which is a religiously
applied version of OCD.
Yeah.
If you're 99% sure that you're
saved, you're a 100% lost.
You're telling children
that they had to be
assured of their salvation.
Wait, wait, so I wasn't told that
and you were there all along,
so we weren't told that.
No, no, I wasn't.
You know I never interacted
with hell that way,
it wasn't something I was
constantly faced with.
It wasn't like it was
constantly talked about.
What we're actually talking about it a lot
and it might give the false impression
that it was shoved down
our throats constantly.
Well, it's not a pleasant
thing to think about.
Yes, so but instead, we
just didn't think about it
and then because it's not pleasant.
And the more you think about it,
I think it gets less pleasant
if not for you, for the
people on the outside.
Yeah.
And so, it's a place I never wanted to go.
I have wanted to go to one of those.
I never went to one of these
Where they scale the hell out of you?
Like a Christian haunted house, yeah.
Just like a Hell House.
Never did that at Halloween.
You would have loved it.
Unfortunately, I wasn't
You would have
come out giddy.
a part of a denomination
that did that kind of thing.
You would have come out satanic.
We just did a Fall Festival
because we didn't believe in Halloween.
But we didn't do Hell houses
and I feel like it was
a missed opportunity.
But this is also the reason
why I don't find Pascal's Wager the same.
I apply the same logic to my
response to Pascal's Wager
as I do to this and that is,
you can take Pascal's Wager
and you can use that
to argue for any faith.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not like--
Because it you they present
it as such a value prop
any faith it presents a value proposition.
That ain't a consequence
for not following it.
So then if you don't, you
can't forget about that value
that's like well if I don't,
I have so much to gain here.
It's not just what you have to lose.
Well, what I'm saying is that,
from a Muslim perspective you
could also have Pascal's Wager
and you could argue that
against a Christian.
You can take and you can start
with particular religious perspective
and say this is what you have to gain
and this is what you have to lose
and then you can argue
from that standpoint
so it doesn't actually it's just not...
It's only compelling to someone
who's trying to hold
on to Christian belief
but it's not very compelling to someone
who doesn't have Christian belief.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
Isn't there also a factor in that
that's like you're not just mentally
assenting to certain beliefs
but you have to have like
a heart connection to it
that you can lead a horse to water
but you can't make it drink.
What kind
of a relationship with God
is that that it's just
based on a fear of Hell
or but well maybe I'm gonna stick around
just in case you guys are right.
That doesn't feel like a
vibrant relationship with God.
It just kind of feels
like a mental exercise.
The second half of this question
or questions that you've grouped together
when you talk about Hell
is what about speaking out?
What if speaking out has led other people
into eternal punishment but
if you're wrong about this?
Right?
Wasn't that in the second
half of the question?
You added that.
But I have seen that.
Like what about the fans and the friends?
Isn't that the question?
You have an answer?
I've seen that one,
I felt like we answered it
towards the end of last week.
I mean when I read the exchange
between two mythical beasts
and it was hey, we're
presenting our perspective
but everyone has to
make their own decision.
I just feel like our
audience can understand that
and I think even if, I
know that a lot of people
were shaken up but again, I
don't think it troubles me
that I just feel like...
I get nervous when I make
generalizations about the church
but I do feel like it's a little,
they err on the side of like okay,
let's not fully engage in our doubts.
Let's not have it's you know,
it just didn't feel like something
that you could talk about freely.
It was like I gotta have a
special meeting with my pastor
and I don't know how
I'm gonna bring this up
and I don't know how he's gonna respond.
It's because it feels like
there's so much at stake,
there's not this open dialogue
where it's like you really can.
It's gonna be normal to have
doubts and to engage in that.
I just don't feel like
that was the environment.
But I feel like that's the environment
that I try to create with my kids.
It's like listen,
don't think that your
daddy knows everything.
Yeah.
And like you said before, it's more about
they learn so much more from our actions
and they do from what we say
that I think that they know
that I don't know everything
but at least I try to be sorry.
That just as one example.
I try to seek forgiveness from
them for things like that.
So what's my point?
I think if I'm gonna open up my kids
to that level of honest dialogue
with wherever they're at,
I'm comfortable doing
that with our audience
and them being able to make decisions,
responsible decisions for themselves
and not just take what we believe,
hook, line and sinker for themselves.
Yeah.
So I just cannot put
that burden on my back
and I'm not gonna do it.
Okay.
Okay, I don't disagree
with anything you just said
but playing devil's advocate,
if I were still a
Christian who believed that
Christianity holds the ultimate
truth to man's salvation.
Yeah.
Then I would believe that
distorting that truth
or misleading people would
be a horrible thing to do
and true, everyone needs
to make their own decision
but you also have a huge platform
and you've got impressionable
kids listening to you
and you're shaking up their situation.
What if you're wrong?
So I don't disagree
with what you're saying.
They need to make their own decision
but you have influence when you speak.
Again, but then my issue with
this particular question--
Well, I hope that was my influence
was that it opened questions.
I get that, you're not wrong.
But I'm saying, the reason
that even just what I said,
playing devil's advocate
,is not compelling to me
is the same reason that Pascal's Wager
is not compelling to me
or the same reason that I don't fear hell.
And that is because the
hell that you're saying
that I might be sending people to,
I don't believe in that hell.
You believe in that hell.
And so, I don't think that
that's what I'm doing.
Of course, if I thought
that that's what I was doing
or if I thought that there
was a reasonable chance
that that's what I was
doing, I wouldn't do it.
Right.
But I don't believe that.
So I actually think that by getting people
to ask those questions
and to kind of explore the
foundations of their faith,
I think that ultimately just as a species
questioning that and
getting closer to the truth
is gonna ultimately serve
everyone's best interest.
'Cause I'm not suggesting something
that you should replace your faith with.
I'm figuring all that out in my own life
but I'm just saying that hey,
if this isn't gonna take
us to the next phase
in our human evolution,
then we got to figure out what is
and we don't need to
try to bring along some,
we don't need to try to bring along
something that's actually not
gonna service our species.
We've got more questions.
We got some more questions
but we are gonna take a short break
and what are we trying to get people
interested in right now?
mythical.com has interest galore, Rhett.
Don't undersell it.
Just because I'm not wearing something,
doesn't mean that mythical.com
is not a burgeoning center.
Well, it was all just a setup
for you, Link because of--
Of mythicality.
What I wanted to say
Free activity curiosity
and tomfoolery on your body, in your hands
When you look at this white
T-shirt that I'm wearing
and you say to yourself man,
think of all the things that
that white T-shirt could be.
This is like a canvas
that I'm planting this
thought in your head
of this white T-shirt that
could be anything you could say,
mythical on it.
Yeah.
It could have a nice
picture of I don't know.
Look at my shirt,
We are selling
so I don't know what to commit to
at this point.
Look at my shirt.
I've had this shirt.
We don't sell anything like that.
I've had this shirt for probably 15 years.
How to kill a mustache,
I was wearing this shirt.
Yeah.
That was a long freaking time ago.
Yeah, it's like a cowboy style,
I still like it.
At a certain point,
you might realize
that you've been wearing the
same clothes for a long time.
mythical.com. can help you with that.
Wrap your boys.
Let's get back into some questions.
Hit it.
Okay.
Now again, you haven't suffered
from this as much as I have
and I'm using the term suffered loosely.
But because my story was very
much my intellectual journey
and I questioned some foundational things
about the Christian faith,
of course, people who know
and care about these things
have suggested many,
many, many, many resources
for me to check out.
And I wanna talk about,
I wanna hear a book report.
Listen, how do I want to get into this
because people have suggested websites,
articles, YouTube videos, books
and all by people who
are probably, definitely
many of them but probably most of them
are smarter than me.
Definitely most of them are
more well studied than me.
They haven't been making YouTube videos
almost exclusively for a decade.
They've been studying these things
and so the people are pointing to me,
pointing me to all these
different resources.
Now, I'm not then taking all the resources
and staying up every night
and just going through all the information
and sort of reading everything
that everyone is sending to me deeply.
And I have a few reasons for that.
The first is that, with a few exceptions,
the general arguments that
people are kind of pointing me to
and the resources,
whether I've looked at those
things specifically before
or things very much like them,
I kind of just want to
and this is a little bit
of a defense of my process
which I said I didn't want to do
but I just feel like I have to say it.
I didn't come to any of my
conclusions lightly, right?
As I said earlier, I wasn't trying
to get myself out of the faith.
Leaving the faith,
was the scariest possible
proposition for me.
Right?
There was so much there for me
and it was a very slow
process over like 10 to 15,
about 15 years
and it was based on looking
at a lot of these types of
resources on both sides.
I know I kind of listed out some resources
when I did my story and
people had a lot to say
about what that indicated.
Those weren't.
That wasn't it.
That wasn't the only thing I looked at.
That was just a small
sampling of some things
that I found compelling
but I don't remember
everything that I looked at.
But I didn't come to any of
those conclusions lightly
so it isn't like, "Oh have
you been to this website
"because they've got all the answers
"that you're looking for?"
It's like, I probably
have seen those answers
and processed those answers
and in the end, after a
layman's investigation
over the course of 15 years,
came to the conclusion
that I just didn't find those
things compelling, right.
So that I'm not super
like chomping at the bit
to get into 'em.
But I wanna talk a little more personally
about why I have a kind of an issue
with the whole enterprise
of like apologetics
and these kinds of resources.
It seems to me that one of the
things that people are doing
is they're saying, "Hey Rhett,
"here's a really smart person
"who knows a whole lot
more about this than you do
"and they've got a really
compelling book about it.
"Check it out."
So there's a tendency, as
I talked about in my story,
to find a smart person, right.
Find a smart person who
believes what you believe
and use that as justification
that it's cool and reasonable
to believe what you believe.
And so you kind of get into this,
appealing to smart people game.
And I don't know how to say this.
I'm trying to be as charitable as possible
but I don't think that this
is a really fruitful game
for certain kinds of Christians to play
because when you get,
depending on the subject,
once you get into the,
hey here's a smart person who
believes what I believe game,
you're gonna find pretty quickly
that you're gonna get outnumbered
by the smart people on the
other side of that issue
that you're trying to get people to see.
Take evolution as an example, right.
The vast majority of biologists,
the vast majority of people
who have given their lives
to studying, you know biology
believe in common ancestry.
So when you find a really smart scientist
who doesn't believe in it and be like hey,
it's like well I can find
a hundred smart scientists
who disagree with him.
So playing that game kind of
defeats itself after a while.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, yeah.
But I see it done so
often and I also did it
but I think that there's very
few issues that I talked about
in my journey, whether you're
talking about archeology
or whether you're talking
about New Testament scholarship
where that wouldn't be the case.
Now interestingly, the closer
and closer you get to Jesus
you know when you get into
like New Testament scholarship,
a lot of people who
have devoted their lives
to the study of the New Testament,
there's a lot, you have to
be a certain kind of person
to get to that point in the first place
so the proportion of people
who disagree about that
is a little bit different
than say evolutionary biology.
Does that make sense?
Definitely.
But you do have plenty
of people who got into it
and dug into it very deeply,
who came out on the other side and said,
oh I got into this because of my love
for an interest in Jesus
and then when I started
seeing the realities,
I actually was very
troubled and moved away.
A lot of people say go to seminary,
there's one of two options.
Either you're gonna
become a deeper believer,
you're gonna you know
your faith is gonna deepen
or you're gonna leave it.
It's not gonna stay the same.
But when you talk about
Christian apologetics in general,
something I thought about recently
because I have been watching
a lot of these podcasts
and going, I still I love,
I'm kind of genuinely
interested in this stuff
so out of my own interest,
I still read these articles
and look at these things to some degree.
But one of the things
that has kind of struck me
about just the enterprise
of Christian apologetics
is that the whole idea is that you can use
basically logic and reason
to make a defense of the Christian faith,
to make it seem reasonable and logical.
But it feels like, and take
the issue of the resurrection
which is kind of the linchpin
of the whole thing right.
So there's plenty of people
who have written books
and I've read them some of them
about why the basically
the best explanation
of the events around Jesus' resurrection
is that he actually bodily
raised from the dead
explains the empty tomb
and explains the start
of the early church,
yada yada yada right.
heard the arguments.
But I find it interesting
that the best defense
of the Resurrection which is a miraculous,
unbelievable, unreasonable,
illogical event
is to use logic and reason
to try to make it seem
like it actually happened.
To me, the resurrection is
the ultimate test of faith.
It is saying I'm gonna believe something
that is unbelievable.
Isn't that what makes it a
beautiful thing to believe
from the standpoint of faith?
But if it really happened,
everything around,
you could have logical,
historical, philosophical,
cultural convert analysis of it.
Right, but I feel like all the historical,
logical analysis of it,
from the standpoint of someone
who's trying to argue the resurrection,
I think they're very much
overstating their case
because I think that it's like again,
I told you I knew somebody
who wrote a term paper
explaining why the resurrection happened
and I feel like they definitely
there's some logical leaps in there
and they're justifying
something that is okay,
it could have happened.
The best you can get to
is it could have happened.
If you believe that
resurrection is possible,
it is possible that Jesus resurrected.
But what I'm saying is that,
to me it feels like you take the magic
and the beauty out of something.
And I'm just using the
resurrection as an example
but what I'm saying is
that post-enlightenment,
all this very super reductionist thinking
that people are applying to the faith,
to God in his action in the world
and people's relationship with him,
to me the reductionism takes
the faith and the supernatural.
We're not talking about reasonable things.
We're talking about God,
this external personal force
moving into the physical world
and doing things that
defy all logic and reason.
So when you start trying to put your logic
and put God into the
reasonable and logical box,
you're kind of taking away
some of his attributes in my mind,
which leads me to,
I personally think the most
intellectually defensible
Christian position is something called
biblical presuppositionilism right,
which is basically you just
start with the presupposition
that the Bible is true
and that everything flows from that.
Now, do I find that compelling?
No.
Do I subscribe to that?
But it I can understand it
and I find that the
people who kind of start
with this presuppositionalist viewpoint
have a lot less trouble getting
into this tit-for-tat logic
and reason argument back and forth
because it's just like
I don't have to deal with your arguments
because it's I just accepted as true.
I just feel like the enterprise
of Christian apologetics
for a lot of people, if you
go into it with an open mind
and an open heart and you kind of say,
I'm gonna follow where that
wherever the truth leads.
I think one of the reasons
that so many people like me
when they take on that particular,
they go down that path
they end up where I'm at
is because exactly what I said
it's because you're taking and
you're applying logic to it
and if you're gonna do that,
you're going to end up in a
logical and reasonable place
which I don't believe is a place of faith.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
I'm not gonna add anything to it.
Okay.
Okay, well, I didn't wanna
spend too much time talk.
Again, I don't I like
talking about that stuff
but I don't want it to be our podcast.
So let's talk about some
more personal things.
Let's go back to as
personal as we possibly can.
And to make this even more personal,
I'm gonna say that this question came from
just say the name, a man named Daniel,
a man named Daniel.
I almost said Damniel, my
character's named Daniel.
He likes to have fun.
What are your takes on miracles
such as healing and unexpected blessings?
And another question,
I don't know if this is
I think I just grabbed
this from somewhere else.
Have you ever had a supernatural
experience and if so,
how would such an experience
fit into your worldview, tell?
Okay.
Have we ever had a--
Lots of people ask this question
Supernatural experience.
How do you,
because a lot of people
said God moved in my life
in an undeniable supernatural way
and therefore, regardless
of what you're gonna say
about the foundation of the faith
it's so real and so personal
and I've seen with my own eyes
or I've experienced something
that is undeniably supernatural
and God's movement in my life
and therefore I'll never depart from him.
How do you relate to that?
Oh you were asking me?
I thought you were restating
the question in general.
Well, I didn't really hear
your restating a question.
'cause I was thinking of if
if I've ever experienced
something miraculous,
I don't remember ever
experiencing anything miraculous.
I think in our particular
church it was like,
we weren't taught to expect miracles.
It wasn't a part of the,
there weren't healings
associated with our church services.
That wasn't the denomination we came from.
Yeah, we pursue it to something
you might call dispensationalism
which is the idea that miraculous activity
by the Holy Spirit coincides
with the dispensation right.
So a dispensation it
like so when obviously,
there's all kinds of miracles in the Bible
because A, Jesus is doing them,
so you've got God in the
flesh, they're doing miracles.
And then you've got all
these early church miracles
when the Holy Spirit is
basically coming on people
at Pentecost and then a few years after.
But God doesn't do
that anymore.
But God doesn't
do that anymore because
he doesn't need to.
That's kind of, but that doesn't mean
that occasionally, God's
gonna answer a prayer
but it'll be one of those things it's like
did this person get better from cancer
because the church prayed
or was it just, it just happened
or was it the medical team?
But it wasn't like
somebody's gonna come in
and like grow hair of a different color
or their legs are gonna get longer,
they're gonna stand up from
being you know disabled
from for 10 years.
Like that didn't happen in our church,
but I do understand that it happens
in many people's traditions.
But based on that teaching,
I never really looked for it.
I never expected it.
I've been thinking like
a corollary question
people have asked it's like
what about answered prayers?
You know, if you wanna put
that like in a near miracle
or like in the miracle category,
I guess they're like miracle light.
That sounds like a beer.
Well, it sounds like a spread.
Miracle Whip.
But I when I was thinking
back, my memory's fuzzy
but my prayer life was not that vibrant
and I don't recall ever
asking God for something
that I didn't think he could give me.
You didn't wanna be unreasonable.
I didn't wanna ask for too much.
That's but when you're taught how to pray,
it's like you got adoration,
you got confession,
you got Thanksgiving
and then if you haven't fallen
asleep by that point, you got
supplication, ACTS.
Supplication, ACTS.
And I never got, I just
I had this feeling that
I just never had, I didn't
wanna call God on the carpet.
I don't know.
It's like I didn't want
to be proven wrong.
Maybe that was part of it
deep down subconsciously.
I had a lot of again
I don't want to go back to the guilt thing
but like I knew that I didn't really
have a great prayer life
and I put that on me.
But I don't remember
ever expecting miracles
or really expecting healing you know.
I especially like after
college in the church
that I was involved in there
it was a different strain of Christianity
and it you know they
started, in that church
we believe that like the people
who were gonna be saved had
been chosen ahead of time
which means that others
were chosen actively
for damnation ahead of time
and there's biblical passages
that seem to say that.
A lot more people believe that
than you would think.
But it was very and you know we
we joked and called
ourselves "the frozen chosen"
because it wasn't a dynamic
experimental expectation.
It was pretty heady.
That God was...
God wasn't gonna show up
and do something crazy
because he didn't need to.
He had already he'd been
there and done that.
You either believe it or don't.
Right.
But don't don't demand it.
Who are you to demand
that God do something?
So this was the environment
that I operated in and
I don't really recall
experiencing a miracle.
One of my mom's friends who was like,
she was she was one of those
what I felt like more the spiritual like
in touch with things that
she that are ineffable
and she was also a Christian.
She said I had this premonition.
It was kind of like a dream
but it was more of a vision
that your son, she was talking to my mom.
Link was in front of this
huge crowd in a stadium
and it was like he was Billy Graham
and he was like preaching the gospel.
And I was in high school
when she told me this.
My mom relayed it and I was like okay,
thanks for that pressure.
I don't know maybe she saw
us performing in a venue
and she didn't realize that
we were just singing a dumb song.
Oh, so I was there?
You were not there.
Okay, well it sounds
like a solo act to me.
Yeah.
To be honest with you.
That hasn't happened.
I mean that that's a
vision, a miracle but...
Well, I have what I would
have called my miracles.
I'm gonna tell my stories.
Okay.
Right now.
All right.
And then I'm gonna tell
you my perspective on them.
First miracle, 1998, I'm in New York City
working with Campus Crusade for Christ
"Summer in the City" is what we called it
where me and I don't know,
30 40 other college students
worked with the churches in the inner city
to do basically you were
with a different church
every single week and doing
whatever outreach and stuff
they were organizing.
And interestingly, one of the things
that I was struggling with at the time,
this is one of my first sort of
I don't remember exactly
where I learned it
but when I started learning more
about how the New Testament came together,
specifically you know the way
the way the Canon was
decided and the counsels
of these church fathers getting together
quite some time after the
the writing of the Bible
to then kind of determine
what the books of the Bible would be.
Yeah, let's not worry
about the book of Thomas.
Exclude some of those books.
And this was troublesome, right.
For someone who had never
really thought about this
and was just like oh,
the Bible is God's Word,
so you kind of just imagined that it was--
It was.
Somebody just you know like I know
I think the the tradition
of the Quran is that
God basically filled Muhammad
and then he wrote it.
I'm ignorant about that.
But I think it has a little
bit in like the tradition
of the Book of Mormon I think is that
God filled the Holy Spirit
kind of came upon Joseph Smith
and got him to write it.
Like that kind of feels like a good thing
to kind of fall back on
like it feels a little tighter
you know from a scripture
standpoint versus like well...
Some people wrote some books.
We don't know exactly
what their intentions were
and then--
Let's get
to the miracle, man.
So you were doubting?
Right.
So I started thinking about this
and had some doubts about it
and I specifically was
arguing with a Muslim student
on some college campus in New York,
I can't remember which one it was.
Not arguing but we're
having a friendly discussion
where he started to attack
the New Testament in this way,
basically saying what I
was just talking to you
from a Muslim perspective
and basically saying how
the Quran is more superior
because of this and I didn't
have any answers for him
because I hadn't really looked into it.
So and of course, I'm in New York,
it's 1998, I don't really
have access to the internet
because we didn't have cellphones
and there was no computer anybody had.
So I didn't really have any
way to research or anything.
So it just kind of ate at me
as I continued to do ministry
throughout the summer.
And then one day, we went square-dancing
because of course square dancing
was what every college student
who knew which way was up
was doing in the late '90s
especially in Christian groups.
Well, we squared-danced like rabbits.
Amen.
I just mixed metaphors there
because we couldn't have sex,
we were square dancing yes.
That's kind of what I was getting
at with the rabbits thing.
Well, you couldn't grind, so you squared?
Right.
And so, we went to the
Lincoln Center or something,
I can't remember we were to square dance
and then we had to come back
and of course we're
using the subway system
and there's no cell phone or anything
so you're like using
your map that you've got
and we realized that the subway station
that we need to get on
the subway we need to
get on to get to a story
which is where we were living had closed
because it was so late
but there was a stop across Central Park
that we could get on
but it was only gonna be open
for like 10 more minutes.
So we all start running
across Central Park,
not the long way, the short way.
It's not that hard to do.
We've got just a little bit of time
to get to the subway station.
We get there, we go down,
we move through the turnstile
and then we get on to the subway
and I go to my seat and right at the seat,
that I'm about to sit down
at, is a sheet of paper.
Okay.
I pick up the sheet of paper
and it's just like a portion of a paper
like a term paper like so just text.
Just typed text.
Typed and put out
Not a professional publication.
And it basically begins to explain
why the New Testament is necessary,
how you couldn't just stop
with the book of Malachi
but that the Old Testament was calling
for the fulfillment in the New Testament.
And I took that sheet of
paper and I said thank you God
for proving yourself to me.
I'm not gonna doubt about this anymore
and put it in my journal.
You stole somebody's paper.
Big Time miracle, right.
What is my perspective on that now?
I told you the story the way
that I've told it many times,
the way I told it to groups of people
when I was a Christian.
you know I'm gonna tell
you the rest of the story
as Paul Harvey would say.
Because the way I told the story,
Paul Harvey wrote most
of the New Testament.
He did.
The Apostle Paul Harvey.
The way that I would tell that story.
What'd you leave out?
Is I told it in a kind
of a sensational way.
Right, I kind of set you
up with what I was doubting
and then I went to this particular seat
that was in the particular
place that I went to
and there's a sheet of paper
and it addressed this thing directly.
Yeah.
The reality of the way that it happened
Sounds like Ear Biscuits.
Well, it made a better story that way
but the reality of the way,
that that's also the way that
I told myself by the way,
when I would go back to that
miracle time after time.
But the way that it actually happened,
everything leading up to
getting on the subway's true
and I was doubting this stuff.
But we got on the subway.
There was flyers like all
over the multiple seats
like it wasn't just the
seat that I was going to,
it was everywhere.
Okay.
When I got to it and read it,
it was someone who is mentally unstable
had written a bunch of sort
of religiously informed gibberish.
Oh, like a manifesto.
And in this and it wasn't
just a sheet of paper
it was a few sheets of paper
and as I read it,
nothing really made sense
and it was like this person
seems a little bit off
but oh but there is a line in here
that says something about and
just like the book of Malachi
is calling out for the book of Matthew
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah.
So I found a sentence.
I was dealing with something in my heart
and it was sort of tearing
me apart in a lot of ways.
And then I found something that
was was quite a coincidence,
was quite serendipitous
and was quite unusual
and I was able to make that connection.
So and and it really put my
doubts at ease at the time.
Now looking back on that,
do I think that that
was orchestrated by God?
Well, if I did then I probably wouldn't
be where I am right now.
No, I don't I think it was a coincidence
that I'd then incorporated
into my framework
and bolstered my belief with it.
My second story, much easier than that.
It was actually that same,
was that the same summer?
I was a camp counselor at a camp
at the tri-state area near New York, yeah
and I had a bunch of inner-city kids
who were coming out to the
wilderness to be in this camp
and these kids come from broken homes
and they were just wild and very difficult
to contain and control.
Okay.
And I was in charge of them.
And one night, they were just
going absolutely ballistic
in this cowled are they
What ages are you talking about?
13.
Okay.
Probably like seven or eight of them
they're going absolutely nuts
and being completely disrespectful
but also like almost fighting each other
and I'm like sitting there
like, I don't know what to do.
So I go outside and
they're like super loud
and like fighting.
I go outside and I place
my hand on the cabin
and pray for peace.
And then immediately, they get quiet.
Wow, did you feel power leave your hand?
No.
Now that's the way I
used to tell the story.
Now I'm going to tell you the
real version of the story.
Paul Harvey.
The rest of the story is--
I never heard that one by the way.
I have heard the other one.
You only told me the first part
which tells me like the
fact that you would even
just by the way, that subway story,
you only told me the first version.
You didn't even tell me like hey man
but there were a lot of pamphlets
and I think that it was
like some weird man.
You never ever told me that.
I hadn't come to grips with
it until more recently.
So it was but it became.
Okay, go ahead.
But the rest of this story is that
I placed my hand on
the cabin and I prayed.
and then a couple of minutes
later, they got quiet.
It wasn't like immediate.
If it had it been, it still
could have been a coincidence
but it was you know.
Did you tell that one publicly?
Yeah.
You did?
And I didn't feel like
I was being dishonest.
It's just when I'm really,
really honest about what happened,
I'm like okay well, you can
change the details a little bit
and make it a little bit more sensational.
Now, so okay, now I'm not
speaking for everybody this is me.
I have no doubt that
people listening right now
there's somebody other here's like
well, I got dude I got specific miracles
that cannot be explained any other way.
Here's what I can say for myself
which is essentially what Link said.
I've never experienced anything
unambiguously supernatural in my life.
Everything that I've experienced,
I can find it isn't difficult for me
to find a reasonable explanation for it.
But a lot of it has to do with the fact
that this the tradition I came from
which we didn't do miracles
and I had a couple of stories
when I was doing some
stuff with Campus Crusade
that I can now see like well,
I mean it could also be a coincidence
so it's not definitively,
it's not unambiguously supernatural.
But the second part of the question is
what would you do if you
experienced a miracle,
an unambiguous miracle
now in the year 2020
thinking the way that you think?
For me, if you go back about five years,
Yeah.
Six years, when I was kind
of making the decision
to be like I'm getting out of this,
I'm not gonna think this way anymore.
An unambiguous miracle at that time
would immediately brought me right back
to traditional Christian faith,
the faith of my teenage
years whatever right.
But I got to be honest with you.
If I experienced something
unambiguously supernatural now,
I would just be like, "Oh,
supernatural things happen."
Oh, that is a feature of the universe,
supernatural things can happen
because I'm not ruling that out
but it doesn't logically follow from me
personally given the conclusions
I've come to up to this point
to then all a sudden,
undo all those conclusions
just because something
supernatural can happen.
To me the only conclusion
that I would come to
is supernatural things can't happen.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Well, for me, if I would
have experienced a miracle
while in the faith,
then I would have picked it apart
because that's what I
was always taught to do
because of what I already said.
I find it interesting that
both of those stories that you told
happened that summer when
you were in New York.
You were serving in churches
that were much more what
we called charismatic.
I witnessed two exorcisms.
You what?
You didn't talk about
what those are miracles.
What do you mean you
witnessed two exorcisms?
Well, I didn't believe that
they were actually exercised.
Because of what we were taught.
Even at the time I was like this
But you were in it okay
so you didn't believe those exorcisms
but man, I want to hear those stories.
Nothing special, no voice
changes, no levitation.
It was like run-of-the-mill,
somebody just yelling really loudly
and everyone's saying
that they were possessed.
So did they--
We're not talking yeah
Did they calm down?
Did something leave their body?
Yeah.
They calmed down.
Okay.
I'll say they calmed down.
That would be, my best explanation.
It was underwhelming to you?
Yes.
It was not believable.
But you were in a more open place
and you were open to looking
and claiming your own
miraculous experience because
I try ask for give the
tongues that summer as well.
In that environment.
like you would never have asked for
to speak in tongues because we were taught
that like again, that
was a prior dispensation
and it was basically just
learning other languages.
But right, but I but I did.
I did ask for the gift of tongues.
it didn't happen.
I did not receive it.
And yeah, I've always just again
it's the combination
of what we were taught
and just how my brain works.
I've always been, I didn't feel
like I needed that to have,
my faith system was intact without that.
So I actually, I didn't need it.
I didn't need to believe those.
I actually feel like right now
I hope that I'm more open to miracles now
because I never have been.
I just want you know, I want...
Again, this is what I want
and how much does that matter
when it comes to what's true.
None.
But maybe it does
because if you don't want something,
Okay, all right.
If you're not open to it,
Preach it brother.
Maybe you can never see the truth of it.
So I want to be open.
I don't want to be shut off to
to God's activity in my life.
I want to cultivate my spirituality.
Yeah, I get that.
And again that's what I've already said
but just to use this, the
miracles as an example,
I'm instinctively skeptical
but I want to be more open.
Yeah.
I'm with you on that.
That sounds good.
I like that.
Yeah, 'cause why not?
I don't wanna miss out on that.
And unless it involves hell,
and then I'm like I don't
know, I don't think I do.
I'm not signing up for
this kit and caboodle.
Okay, I think I follow.
One of the things I will say is that
as a Christian and
especially as a Christian
in a particular denomination
which it was nondenominational
but it was essentially
like reformed Baptist
or something like that, I
don't wanna argue, dude.
But we were really good at
discounting all kinds of miracles
from other traditions,
including the Catholic tradition, right.
The Catholic tradition is kind of known
for ongoing miracles and they have
like a whole group of people
who like verify miracles
that happen at certain locations
and they're kind of more into that.
And our perspective on that was all bull.
I mean to be quite honest.
is it was just bull.
It was like it was wishful thinking
but it wasn't actually happening.
And it was really like it was so, so easy
to not consider Catholic
miracles as a Protestant.
It was so easy, it was
like turning over in bed.
Oh easy.
It didn't even cross my
mind, it was so easy.
So I just find it interesting that like
I never I've never believed in ghosts.
I never really did believed in demons.
We have friends now that like
talk about seeing ghosts,
I'm like well--
I just wanna I want to finish my point--
Okay, sorry.
Because I don't want to people to think
that I'm talking crap about
Catholics in particular.
What I'm doing is I'm just saying that.
You're talking crap about Catholics?
No.
I'm saying that the perspective
that I was under at the time
was that that wasn't legitimate
and so and I didn't care about whether
or not they were offended, right.
And so what I'm saying now is that,
I believe that the miracles
that people, again.
I don't know, my guess
is that the miracles
that people experience today
in the context of church
or any religion are probably
not actually miracles.
That's my, I could be wrong.
It certainly doesn't help
when you've got the easiest targets
of televangelists rigging miracles.
Yeah.
Every time you drill down
That's definitively proved
again and again.
Every time you drill down
on on these guys
who are healing people is that
oh, he's got an earpiece.
Everybody's got an earpiece.
The apologist guy.
That explains it.
He's got an earpiece.
but finish your point.
Ghosts may exist, man.
I never believed in ghosts demons
and now we have close
friends who like talk
about specific and ongoing encounters
of you know and it's like well, you know
my former self would just be like just
almost would talk shit behind your back.
Well, you and I would right?
Yeah, I don't do that anymore.
Well, I like the idea of ghosts
because it makes horror
movies a lot scarier
and I like being scared.
And the moment that you begin
just explaining it all away
and saying that this does
it just can't happen,
then all of a sudden Annabelle's room
is not that scary.
You know what I'm saying though?
Yeah, I just, and I'm
not to that point yeah.
So, there could be something there.
I'm just again, I'm just
trying to give my perspective.
Speaking of your perspective,
I do wanna get your perspective
on leaving me on the side of the road
because some people, it's like they only
they got upset with you.
Maybe I told the story wrong but to me
well, I'll let you speak but it was like
they were angry with you
but I guess it was maybe
at that point in the story.
Yeah.
And then you came back.
I found it really interesting
that people were upset with me.
Once you hear the whole story,
that's an interesting take.
I think it's just a misunderstanding but--
Yeah and we're like--
I didn't say anything
at the time because you
were telling your story,
I didn't wanna, it wasn't
about my perspective so--
There's a few logistical
questions that we did get.
Like we were on Philip DeFranco's podcast
which should be out by now.
We talked about a lot
of this stuff by the way
and he asked us about a lot of questions
about how we're processing
"the Lost Years".
So if you wanna listen to his podcast,
we got into it over there
and got into some stuff
that we haven't talked about here
and that we probably won't.
Yeah.
I got a little carried away a few times.
In a way that I tried
to control myself a little bit
more on you focused.
Yeah, you felt like it wasn't your show
so you could write.
Yeah.
He asked us a clarifying point that like
yeah, you didn't drive all the way home.
You drove over the hill
,you drove over the horizon
and apparently parked somewhere
where then you could walk
and dramatically come over the horizon
which you definitely did.
Yeah, well just to give
you my perspective on this.
So, I was I was upset with
you for drinking right
because I knew--
We were in the band.
Not because I was an asshole but because
we had basically made like
a commitment to each other
and to God that we're not gonna do that,
we're not gonna be kids who party.
That's not what we do.
Jesus is our party.
We were in the "Wax Paper Dogs"
and we as a band, had made a commitment.
Every time we got together to rehearse
which was at least once a week.
It was like such an important.
We would sit down in a circle
and we would pray with each other
and we would share struggles
we were going through.
We would encourage each other
and hold each other accountable
to not holding up the
commitments that we had made
and asked our fellow band
members to hold us to.
So it was something
that I had put out there
hey, I wanna be a positive example,
we want to invite our
friends to these concerts,
we're gonna give people an opportunity
to like become a Christian.
And I don't wanna blow that
by there being cracks in my armor.
Basically, we thought--
So I invited it.
We had to be different
and we had to have a tangible
difference in our life
and one of those easy tangible differences
was we don't get drunk.
We don't get drunk on wine,
we get drunk on the Holy Spirit.
And so or what was it vodka,
I don't know what you had that night.
Some sort of liquor I did not know.
We don't get drunk on some sort of liquor
I do not know.
We get drunk off the Holy Spirit
because of that witness we called it.
Once I said that I wanted to get drunk,
they put on Merle Haggard misery and gin.
Yeah, they knew they got you and got
Merle get you but--
That's a good song
But because you did that,
I knew that--
That's what
I was that night.
Let's say it was gin.
Okay.
You had basically compromised your witness
and so you'd compromised
the band's witness
and as your friend who knew that,
you didn't want to do that ultimately
and you felt bad about it.
I was like well, what am I gonna do?
I'm going to, and again as we
explained on Phil's podcast,
we were, man, we were so dramatic,
sensational like everything was like,
we was like we were ritualistic.
We were trying to create,
make everything that
we were doing cinematic
and like have this
ceremonial aspect to it.
Sure, the big rock and the little rock
that we had in the confessions we had.
The blood oath was a ceremony.
We grew up in a church where I mean it was
it was new form Baptist ceremony
like it was like church
camp tike ceremony stuff
but it was it was meaningful and
I think it's part of that
but I think this is also me
and just the way me and
you have always been.
Yeah.
In the way we conducted
our friendship.
We were strange.
You name places like you
know if you find a tree,
we'll call it "the Tree" with a capital T.
You got to make the fabric of life
be even more exciting than it already is.
I'm not cotton.
Right
Mylar, we were Mylar.
But so, what I was
thinking was is like okay,
he shouldn't have done this
and I need to communicate two things.
I need to communicate
judgment and forgiveness.
Judgment and mercy.
And so it's like to me,
the perfect and I was kind
of just pulling this out of
my ass as I was doing it.
But I was like all right,
I'm gonna kick him out with the car
and drive over the hill
because at that point,
he'll be like damn my friend
just kick me out of the car.
Yeah.
For drinking, I feel I bad.
feel the weight of my sin.
Exactly and then I was like
but I'm not an asshole.
I'm gonna park the car
and walk back to him
in this like moment of cinema
and peek over the horizon
and come and join you
and not say a word.
And by coming back over the
horizon and meeting you,
I'm basically saying
hey man you screwed up
but I love you, I forgive you,
now let's walk together,
let's get back to the destination.
Let's not do that again.
That's what I was thinking.
and I you know I don't even though
I don't feel exactly the way
that I felt at that time,
I don't think the same way
that I think at that time
like I regret many things in life.
I don't regret any of that.
I don't regret that.
Right, yeah.
And you know, I don't
regret getting mad at you
for getting drunk when
you were 16-years-old.
I don't think that
16-year-olds should get drunk,
not from a moralistic standpoint
but it's just like hey,
it's probably not a great idea.
Yeah.
There's consequences to your actions
and it doesn't have to be
that the consequence is
that God is then mad at you.
You don't have to go there
to know that no no there's
immediate tangible consequences
to that kind of behavior.
You don't have to be a
genius to extrapolate
and figure out what those things are.
The risk of swallowing a
penny being one of those.
Right.
You could choke on a penny and die.
Yeah, so you know what next time,
yeah, next time you do something stupid,
I'm gonna leave you on
the side of the road.
I'll do it tomorrow.
You did plenty of stupid stuff
but I never got that
dramatic with you, man.
Yeah.
I didn't I didn't do that
particular thing I don't know.
The first drink I had
You did, it was the girls.
For you it was the girls.
Besides the wine that
we made for ourselves,
when we were like 15.
Which we couldn't have got drunk off that.
That was a question.
We couldn't have got drunk off that
but we thought we could
and we were it was just so
exciting we had to do it,
I mean we weren't perfect.
It was justifiable because--
Yeah, it was justifiable
because Jesus made water into wine.
That's not how we justified it.
We were just like although
there are some Baptists
who think it was grape juice
which still makes me
laugh to this day, but...
It was the girls for you, man.
I liked the ladies.
We had to have a lot of conversations.
At a certain point, I think
you just stopped telling me
what you were up to.
I mean you gotta figure things out.
You would tell me and I would,
then the wheels will start turning
and I'd be like I think
if I'm not upset with him
and that might mean I can do it too
with my girlfriend.
Not sex.
I mean we weren't even
You're using
that term loosely.
I didn't do it.
Yeah, just a little petting.
We called it heavy petting.
It was you, I didn't do it but if it was--
I've never heard of the term heavy petting
outside of like a purity culture.
It's weird like heavy petting
it's like it's just a weird phrase.
I've never seen a "no heavy petting" sign
at a petting zoo, so it's like...
Careful.
I was not tempted, I did not need a sign.
Oh man, I needed that laugh.
No heavy petting.
I'm sure that's on a poster somewhere.
Okay, I mean--
Do you get through everything
you wanna get through?
There's one more question
that I feel like we should answer
even though I think that
we've probably sort of hinted at this.
What?
Jeez, a lot of people
have asked the question.
Well, a guy named Cody asked this question
because I did write it down.
Just about the part of your story.
Again, the question is just
about the part your story
where you make it a point several times
to talk about how real your
relationship was with Jesus
just to later claim he isn't real.
How could it be both?
A lot of people have
asked this question like
I understand he said that it was real,
it seemed like he was as real
as if he physically
manifested himself to you.
Again, this answer is
not gonna be satisfactory
to anyone who believes that
they are actually in a
relationship with God
or in a relationship with Jesus.
You're gonna conclude that
we just never had a real
relationship with Jesus
if this is the way that
we would characterize it
and that yes, you're right.
I can't really, I honestly
can't argue with it.
But I believe that we
were a part of a community
that was committed to a
certain way of seeing the world
and we had lots of people in our lives
who were reinforcing that viewpoint
and that was kind of every
single thing, it was just.
We bought into a philosophy right
and part of that religion,
part of that way of thinking
was that you basically, you're
in relationship with God
like basically, you are in
a relationship with Jesus
but it's really the Holy Spirit
that's filling you and motivating you
and keeping you from doing things.
And there were times
when I would specifically
be singing praise and worship music
which was a big part of
the groups that we were in.
And I would just feel
completely overwhelmed
and we didn't do the whole like
getting slain in the spirit.
Never got knocked down by anybody
but had deeply emotional reactions
during different conferences
in places where you were
just like on fire for God
and I actually had physical
things happen to me
like I would feel like a tingling
kind of coming down
from the top of my head
and getting in my ears and
there's like a physical manifestation
of what I thought at the time
was the Spirit filling me.
Interestingly, I can listen
to praise and worship music
to this day and kind of get
myself back into that place.
I can listen to "Easy
Lover" by Phil Collins
and that other guy and
get into that place.
But so I think a lot of
the things that I was
I mean just the tingling.
I was interpreting
as evidences of the Holy Spirit
when it's evidences of the
way humans work you know
and they were deeply emotional and--
But there was, and I know
this is true of you too
but like I was journaling my prayers
because I had a hard time
actually focusing on praying
but there was a lot of praying.
It was kind of a one-sided conversation
but when you start to,
I could sense responses.
Oh, yeah.
Like you read the you know
they taught you, we were
taught to read the Bible
and study the Bible in a
way that the Holy Spirit
would bring things out of it
like you would gain insight
and relating it to who you were
and we would seek guidance
on every single major decision
and it's certain stints of my life
every single minor decision.
Yeah.
And you really get a sense that you were
that I was guided to make decisions by God
I mean we even went through workbooks
called "Experiencing God"
"How to determine God's
will for your life"
all of the, it's like we were trained
the practices in order to connect with God
and to be guided by God.
But for me, making
decisions was a huge thing
like my journal was filled with everything
that I talked about and
then the second thing
that was filled with
was me trying to assess
if I could marry Christy,
if she was the one for me
like I obsessed about this and I felt like
on one hand, I became convinced that like
okay God is blessing this decision
this is a wise decision,
this is the right decision.
On the other hand, I
feel like I missed out
on a lot of like experience and
like falling in love with my wife
because I wanted it to be such a,
I wanted it to be something
where God granted me permission
and give me a sign or
give me the specifics
and I felt like I got
that, those are all aspects
of my active relationship with God.
You're the one who made the statement
I didn't make the statement
but it's true of me too.
I believe that I did have
a real back-and-forth conversational
relationship with God.
I just thought that I wasn't good at it
and that all the stuff
I was trained to do,
I just wasn't motivated enough
and it was my shortcomings not God's
that that made me feel distant.
Yeah well, you know when you're on staff
with Campus Crusade you have,
you're encouraged to do something called
"A day with the Lord" every month, right.
Right.
And this is essentially
a day-long devotional.
You might have what we
call your quiet time
or your devotion time every single morning
where you get up and you
pray and you read the Bible
which I was okay, yeah, I
had some good runs in there.
It's pretty much a struggle
for most Christians.
But I always loved the day with the Lord.
You did?
Oh, yeah I I loved it
and what I would do is
I would take my Bible and my journal
and I would go to some spot in nature
and I would just sit there
and I would just pray
and basically, the funny thing is
is I still do this, pretty regularly.
I just don't call it
"A day with the Lord".
I just go out into a spot in nature.
I don't have the Bible,
I've got my journal.
I might have a book or something
that I'm reading at the time
but I just sort through things, right.
And it's just like now I
talk out loud to myself
whereas I used to just
talk out loud to God
but tangibly, practically, the
experience is no different.
I'm not trying to yeah,
that may sound like sad
or crass or whatever but
I'm just saying that.
Not trying to be dismissive
I'm just saying when I think back
on what I was interpreting
as a two-way relationship
where the Lord was again,
I don't know the nature of the universe
and maybe that I was tapping
into some sort of
spiritual plane that exists
that I don't fully grasp and understand
and I'm still open to that.
I hope so.
Yeah.
But I tend to think
that what was happening
especially during those times
is I was just getting away.
I was extracting myself
from my day-to-day life
and all the distractions there
and I was just getting some time
to just be still you know.
Be still and be in a meditative state
and kind of just things
come to the surface
and you kind of work through things.
It's like if you go to the grave site
of someone that you love
and you talk to them
and some people carry on
that kind of relationship
for a very, very long time.
That person never speaks back to them
but there are tangible experiences
and they remember what they looked like
and they remember that
you know in the same way
that your memories of a loved one
are sort of, it's the raw material
by which you have an ongoing
conversation with them
after they die.
I kind of feel like the
Bible and church tradition
and what you're being
taught is the raw material
for carrying on a relationship with Jesus
that might just be a
conversation with yourself.
That's my best guess as
to what's happening there
as I always like to say, I could be wrong.
You probably are.
Right, I'm sure I am in some way.
Yeah.
#EarBiscuits.
At this point, are we gonna talk
about this anymore directly?
I don't know, I don't.
I predict not.
But again, as we've said before,
I think that these things
will percolate through in
as we continue to reminisce
and air every single Ear
Biscuit or every couple,
I mean we're always pulling from our past
and now we're able to
talk about it in a way
that we haven't been able to.
Yeah.
Certain aspects of that.
I gotta say it's-
So we'll come up.
It's been really ,really
liberating, personally.
I think about just being
able to talk about it
on Phil's podcast and you
know, there was a lot of shame
and also just fear
around just being honest
about our pasts and you
know be able to just be like
this is who we were, this is who we are.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's a healthier way to live.
I've experienced a lot of peace.
And we can move forward.
That's so important.
I feel like, and I'm
glad that in this venue,
you can come along for the ride.
That's what's gonna happen.
Do you have a wreck?
I do have a wreck.
I have a wreck and a fact.
Hit us with it.
I wanted to do this last
week but it was your wreck,
so it's a little bit late but
I just wanted to shout out
Dear Hank & John, which is
Hank and John Green's podcast.
Good friends of ours
and John shouted us out
and I'm not just doing
this to return the favor
I mean that's part of this but John
has been listening to the podcast.
I'm not saying Hank hasn't,
but John specifically said
that he had been listening to our stories
and our deconstruction
and just the way that he
described it on their podcast,
it just meant a lot to us
and they're also just
super thoughtful guys
who basically as close to us as you can be
in terms of well, two guys
who have known each other
for most of their lives.
Probably theirs are like all their lives
who do a business like this
and are just trying to
be husbands and fathers
and live life and figure it out
and they're just incredibly
smart, thoughtful, funny guys
who have a very smart,
thoughtful, funny podcast.
But they've got this thing
where you can only listen to it
after you've listened to Ear Biscuits.
That's how their podcast works.
Right, so do that before--
So don't even try.
Yep.
to listen to it before you've listened to
and you've fully caught up with us.
But then go on over there
and they'll welcome you with open arms.
All right.
We'll speak at you next week.
Love you.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.